I started an internet trend and this is
the story this story starts on a lazy
Sunday I was hanging out in my apartment
alone just having a weird day sometimes
I like to have weird days and I had play
Nintendo and I eat stuff and I drink
beer and it's great so this is one of
those Sundays and I'm scrolling social
media which is my favorite thing to do
and I noticed that there's this whole
conversation going on about the way
ariana grande is dressed on this album
cover some people are saying that a
woman shouldn't have to dress like that
because she's a singer what is her body
have to do with it other people were
saying that she should dress however she
wants even though this album came out
three years ago everyone was dissecting
what she's wearing I was staring at this
album cover for like an hour for a
different reason
she is seated on the stool in a way that
didn't make sense to my brain it's like
one of those drawings from a staircase
that goes on forever it was like an
optical illusion I didn't understand how
it was physically possible that this
picture could have been taken she's
kneeling in this way like even my hands
feel awkward trying to do it but it does
look plausible enough where maybe she
did take the photo it wasn't like oh
this is an obviously bad Photoshop and
was driving me [ __ ] crazy so at first
I'm genuinely not thinking about social
media or the Internet and I filled up my
camera roll with photos of myself
kneeling on a stool in front of a mirror
to try to see if I could do it I
couldn't first of all I fell down
multiple times I almost broke my arm and
I'm looking back through all these
photos I'm like I look [ __ ] crazy
right now but I feel like other people
would be interested in this I pick a
couple of photos that show I'm really
struggling I also pick ones that don't
clearly show my face because it's a
little embarrassing so I posted it to
Twitter then I usually take my tweets
and I screen grab them and put them on
Instagram a hashtag ariana grande no one
really notices it for a couple hours I
continued drinking beer and playing
Zelda and then my phone starts blowing
up I realize it's taken off on Instagram
be posting the Instagram the most amount
of people that usually are gonna like
something are your followers and I
didn't have that many followers at the
time all of a sudden it has four
something thousand likes I'm getting
tagged in photos of people trying it
themselves
now people are going back to finding me
on Twitter posting replies to my
original tweet of them doing it I can't
understate how quickly this thing was
just blowing up my mentions my phone was
hard to use it was running so slowly it
was like from Instagram and Twitter just
buzz buzz buzz I started actually
getting nervous I'm like what if there's
something in the background of the photo
that people are just gonna make fun of
me for what if my job has some weird
deal with ariana grande that they're
like you blew it when I walk over to my
phone and pick it up and see my latest
notification it said ariana grande
replied to your tweet I'm assuming at
this point this is a fan account if you
look at like pop stars like Taylor Swift
or Lady Gaga ariana grande they have
these huge fan accounts some of them are
verified I thought this was one of them
I opened Twitter I see ariana grande
actually quote tweeted my tweet next
week on Mythbusters and at that point
I'm like [ __ ] she is one of the biggest
Twitter accounts young fans are a
horrifying force if they think that
you're going after a star you're done so
I was immediately terrified that are
gonna grande interacted with it because
I was like okay the fans are coming for
me it was like I felt the [ __ ]
Stampede
luckily this was a positive force they
were all happy about it they're all
positive about it which was great my
Instagram followers grew like crazy
which is good but it's a lot of ariana
grande fans who are gonna be sadly
disappointed when I post the next like
selfie at this point things went from
being let's say blowing up on social
media to viral
I think people throw around the word
viral people will say this went viral
when really it just got shared and
they're like local fishing community
Facebook page and that's pretty much
everything I have ever posted that's
done super well has been like oh yeah
this like this corner of the internet
who loves the movie hocus pocus shared
this thing but I wouldn't say it went
viral to me something actually going
viral means that your mom's neighbor's
hairdresser knows about it I'm getting
emails from Good Morning America I got a
message from someone at the view there's
one from Australia there's one from like
the Netherlands there's like an
international television producers we're
messaging me and emailing me so I'm just
honestly excited by this it is
nerve-racking
when TV shows reached out I'm thinking
use the photos all you want talk about
it I do not want to be on TV talking
about how I spent my Sunday in my
underwear taking pictures of myself in
an ariana grande pose I just couldn't do
it
I think the pinnacle of what I would
call this going viral like something
actually going viral is my mom texting
me saying she's at the nail salon and
opened in Touch magazine and saw a story
about the ariana grande stool thing that
mentioned me to me the watermark of
viral is now if your mom texts you from
the nail salon that she just read in a
magazine about the thing you made
there's a lot I learned from this
experience it was really nice seeing
that you can make something that's just
earnest just an observation it wasn't
making fun of ariana grande it wasn't
making fun of the people who designed
the album cover it wasn't making fun of
her fans it was just something that
universally was a fun thing to
participate in I basically ended all of
it by trying the stool challenge myself
for real this time and I just posted a
photo that was me in the stool as best
as I could pose that said myth plausible
to this day I do not think I've seen one
person successfully pose in the same way
she did this happened last year but I'm
gonna say the challenge lives on if
you're watching this try it yourself and
tag me if you think you can actually do
it because I don't think it's actually
been done so far
[Music]